registrando a 321 sì sì lo so questo
quello che ha fatto ma la vuoi fare
aspettano in tre mesi è così noi
cambiamo la scena non cestinare non so
fare queste cose che stai facendo che
figata come farlo youtube grazie che nel
catania napoli scolo webcam facciamo
facciamo c'è un libro 6
ciao a tutti stiamo mette per i ragazzi
ovviamente questo io vi do io sono d'oro
sono due mesi io sono capi gip a vincere
ma non è vero sì und rambla mi ha dato
questa cosa la sa aula gli hai dato
questa roba perché tipo i capelli
normalmente sono così quindi senza
professionisti con questa è medico e si
sto qui sembrano sei un nano stefano è
alto 140 bene andiamo solo cambiano la
scelta che possiamo partire ragazzi ciò
che stiamo al sud come noi mai fatto
possiamo nuovo britti da due scelte e tu
devi cliccare il bottone solo faresti o
no c'era la rana spera sbagliato
qui ti dice una cosa che è il superfiga
però allo stesso tempo di da anche se tu
scegli di fare quella cosa ti dà anche
una cosa negativa è che fosse invisibile
che tu premieresti subito se il cane
piccolo invece il cazzo peak ma c'è il
caso piccolo tatuaggio interessi di
essermi tv deve avere il cazzo piccolo e
che senso ma poi ma sempre seguire la
legge e giù il cazzo gigante
avrai l'abilità di cambiati e di essere
la creatura che vuoi un arco grifo
ma devi rimanere quell'animale per un
mese intero ogni volta che tu cambi ma
basta stare attenti a crescenti io sono
un cazzo di dinosauro permessi io per me
va bene accettate tipo 68 hanno scelto
sistemico per avere l'abilità di creare
te stesso
la tua realtà vuol dire ti crei quello
che vuoi davanti è mirata e bonera
territorio anche tu mi straccio lupo
insomma sul suo stesso sorial power
quando dice queste cose siete resi conto
ma neanche letto gli effetti contratto
hai detto che hai cliccato che aspetta
adesso leggiamo galera negativo dopo 25
usi sarai fermo nella realtà e non
potrei andare indietro ma puoi risolvere
tutti i problemi del mondo ma rimarrai
assassinato quel caso se ne frega
assassinato col cazzo non voglio morire
ok allora non ho mai usato un giorno
dopo cioè in crosta scelto stefano bravo
fanno tutti e tre stagioni non troppo
lunga non ci voglio avrai l'opportunità
di risolvere tutti i problemi del mondo
ancora aspetta malattie è però non ti
puoi più masturbare per il resto della
tua vita
e allora no perché io devo tagliare
tutto questo video liberal anno circa
secondi di bella a tutti ragazzi e basta
no io avrei premuto la gente ammesso sì
ma la falcone visto avrebbero in tutti i
preti questo gioco puoi far morire
chiunque ti voglia desktop ma dovrai
dormire in una metropolitana a tutti i
mercoledì pomeriggio kick ass hanno
fatto gli atti pubblici
si prega per me riccio comunque va bene
potrei sembrare come la tua celebri tra
celebri tratte ho sempre sognato di
essere papig ma parli nella voce del
sesso per api che quel vocione da uomo
donatrice
[Musica]
avanti dai 36 per cento ha messo no
qualcosa e puoi disegnare qualcosa
istantaneamente in modo perfetto e
portare vita all'arte check tu crei crei
la cosa che disegni l'effetto negativo è
che rimette disegni mentre dormi e tutto
ciò che sogni per lo più sono incubi
quindi tipo il mondo avrà conquistato
dai tuoi incubi per me no quindi rari
ragni completo che me frega un cazzo
disegna fare allora sarei la persona più
ricca e famosa del mondo ma morirai di
droga tra vent'anni ci sta quinta come
ci sta
ma che cosa giusta ma poi è meglio 20
anni di abrogato che non c'entro dannato
ostinato avrà i poteri di un grande
sottocapo di poteri a uno squalo di
avere la gente a qualche batteremo
perché posso fare se smetti di muoverti
morì sul fugati no non ha senso se dormi
muri quindi tutto ciò che dici diventerà
realtà dirà il contrario di quello che
il principale di parlare al contrario no
non voglio e mi di ratei toschi in
questo sta non dovete mettere mi piace
vedete mi piace al visivamente ma vj fa
parte dei me lo faccio per voi mi hai
un'infinita quantità dietro ieri juan ha
capito che da questo video c'è marijuana
video youtube lo censura non c'è niente
per tutte le volte che fumi una ragione
a caso muore justin bieber muore ma
selena gomez diventa un clone di majlis
d'onore vista sì l'inter trovare sempre
il cuore il progetto esplora piaciute
scena ma chi è che si rispetti computer
chi è che mancano sappiamo denunciamo
per il trend il 66 per cento ha detto sì
ha detto sì in questo mondo merita
donald trump [ __ ] avrai tanti
soldi quanto vorrei per ogni 1.000
dollari che hai una persona muore ma vai
a morire la gente morti oggi
ma veramente da questa roba qua e
aggiornato perché c'è un nucleo
la sua giunta è morto nella statistica
ha la meglio degli anni e quindi secondo
la spesa pubblica per la sanità 7
miliardi sporca [ __ ]
quindi mentre stiamo facendo questa roba
sta per televisori venduti o c'è
qualcosa che statistica è comunque io si
premerà i fisici siamo tanti almeno
presentare dado famiglia di browser
sempre insieme a te quindi anche tu cosa
sa che anche tu viveva tutti gli altri
radio miletto famiglia muoiono
io non farebbe no famiglia si intende
anche la persona che io e sposo quindi
va da sé lo vaganti cugini tutti qual è
pero io vado a selena gomez e diventa
mia moglie fa portare la mia famiglia
abbiamo per sempre in culo tutti capito
ma è la morte che dà valore alla vita fa
dj e la vita che dà valore alla foto
andiamo avanti sarà il famoso in tutto
il mondo ma tutti quanti pronunciandone
sbagliato e con i suoi ragazzi quindi è
stata cosa molto triste compreso i
capelli mm da parte di emily e la bella
è possibile preme il bottone cancellare
quello che abbiamo per registrare però
perde tutti i soldi che hai
non prendiamo molto quindi ragazzi se
questo video è piaciuto al suo documento
mi piace però dobbiamo parlare al
contrario fare st carlini non lasciate
il ragazzo in questo video che ha fatto
schifo mettete un bel dislike posteriore
ha fatto schifo così sia la sequela
ragazzi